this year we decided that we would have
an event in which people from a
different field would take a different
look at the same question and the
question was who are you so Irene bloom
rad who is someone who studies identity
citizenship immigration is going to make
the case that you are actually your
citizenship the question about who are
you and and the answer around identity
isn't just a question about you know a
maya toronto maple leafs fans versus a
kennedy infant or a Maya Canadian or an
American or those kind of things it's
also a question about how our identities
are constituted and in my particular
case I am elaborating a way of thinking
about this that says that public
policies what government does really has
an impact on how I see myself and how I
see myself as a member of society or a
member of different groups within that
society Alex Haslam was a social
psychologist has done a lot of research
and he truly believes that you are your
social groups I would argue that if you
like the self as a core psychological
contract is at the center of social
behavior all social behavior is informed
by people's sense of self so you know
how if you're a woman and you've got
children how you define yourself as a
mother is going to affect how you bring
up your children
Clyde hertzmann who is an epidemiologist
in other words somebody who studies the
incidence of health and illness in large
populations and he's going to make the
case that you are something about the
relationship between the genes you were
born with and the environment with which
your genes have interacted from the
perspective that I'm going to bring to
the discussion which is very much about
understanding how the social world in a
sense gets under our skin and influences
the way in which our brains develop and
the way in which the rest of our biology
develops such that you get differences
in health well-being learning and
behavior across the life course in
predictable ways in different walks of
life if you didn't ask the question I
think we would never come up with
adequate appropriate useful explanations
or understandings of the world around us
I think it's that fundamental I don't
think you can understand economics I
don't think you can understand society
without understanding that question I
mean the whole point of the next big
question events is to get people to
actually come and talk with us and
listen to our researchers and discover
that what they're thinking about matters
to them the next big question is really
a wonderful bridge between those two
parts of CFR where on the one level you
have the deep engagement with
fundamental research that has done over
long time horizons and the other pillar
of the bridge is really rooted in making
sure that that is relevant or
communicated to a broader audience